it's easy to say that this has been a
year of ups and downs mostly downs in
the real world but hey in the anime
sphere of things everything's been
looking up case in point smash hits that
we've all had the pleasure of seeing as
well as the continued rise of anime's
popularity will fall 2022 be able to
maintain the momentum that spring in
presumably summer will leave us with
that is what we're talking about today
and in case you're wondering what kind
of shows to pick up for the last quarter
of the year perhaps this list can help
you make your choice here are what i
think are the top 10 most anticipated
titles this fall 2022. starting out this
list is reincarnated as a sword
[Music]
we've seen people reincarnated as all
sorts of things in the world of anime
but how about a sword for a change of
pace this is certainly treading some new
horizons for the isekai genre and it
does actually lead to some interesting
results our protagonist finds himself
waking in the middle of a forest of
beasts and he encounters the catgirl
fran saving her in the process bearing a
heavy past of persecution fran longs for
freedom and revenge and this encounter
with a sword turns out to be the major
turning point in her life with a new
partner in hand she embarks on a journey
of redemption the enemies are many but
the two will also need to learn and
accept each other to survive in their
perilous journey how will this
formidable team of fran and the newly
christened shisho fare against the
challenges in the adventure ahead let's
join the strongest duo's adventures this
october 2022
[Music]
[Music]
gives us a blast from the past in the
ninth slot
here's an old school show that i didn't
expect to get a remake rumiko
takahashi's first manga gets the remake
treatment and it's one the fans haven't
necessarily asked for but do welcome
with open arms the stories about the
purvi
and this encounters with alien invaders
known as oni sent to represent humanity
in a duel against the oni ataru manages
to win against the aliens
representatives lam however victory
turns into misfortune as lum starts
developing an attachment to our
protagonist deciding to move in with him
as if the consequences of his womanizing
ways aren't bad enough ataru now must
deal with this alien who can be more
than a handful urusai yatsura has been
one of the more influential title in the
80s a trendsetter if you will in the
realm of anime tropes and fanservice i
can only wonder how this will fear after
being given the modern treatment we
won't have to wait too long to find out
as it comes to us this fall
eminence in shadow creeps in as the
eighth entry on the list
[Applause]
we all have our moments of delusion we
imagine things and often bask ourselves
in grandeur however some are more like
sid gargano preferring to be the type of
character who plays a mastermind behind
the shadows the overlord behind the
scenes if you will he gets his wish
granted after reincarnating he takes the
role of a mob character recruiting a
group of cute and badass girls into his
organization shadow garden together they
look to take down a mysterious cart born
from his own imagination unfortunately
things may not be as smooth of a sailing
as sid imagined and even more real and
sinister threats lurk past the facade of
the diobolas cult shadowgarden versus
the dear bowler's cult who will prevail
join sid and his team in this anime
that's not just your everyday power
fantasy
spy family part two is seventh on the
list
just when you thought it was all over
lloyd your and anya are coming back to
our screens to give us more of the crazy
funny wholesome and exciting now that
didn't take too long but it's not
surprising given the show's popularity
and the stellar reception the fans have
given him spy family is easily a
contender for one of the more popular
anime this year and those who've watched
its first season can see why it just
brings with it such a fresh approach and
feel for modern anime spy family is one
of those shows you turn on to unwind and
as far as the entertainment goes it does
the job super well memes galore and
genuinely touching moments away those
who watch the hottest show in 2022.
who's up for more spy family i sure am
and it's going to be one of the top
highlights of fall 2022.
[Music]
in the sixth launch we have my hero
academia's sixth season todo kai
horthinson
[Music]
it is all sheer coincidence but one of
the most popular shonen out there will
be having its sixth season in the anime
60th anniversary six years is a lot and
fans have had their share of awesome
action thrilling revelations and
tear-jerking drama and guess what
they'll be back for more this season
looks to wrap up the rise of villain
saga in a big way being someone who's
read the manga let me tell you to gear
up for the end game nothing will be ever
the same again once this arc is done and
i can only hope that the anime
adaptation will do justice to this arc
that leads us towards the final stretch
of the manga it's pretty much a shoe in
that we're getting a full adaptation at
this point so here's hoping for another
amazing season as we head to the finish
line i'm seeing a full adaptation to be
around eight seasons so there's that
[Music]
and if you like what you've seen so far
and haven't subscribed yet help the
channel out and hit that subscribe
button up there it doesn't take too long
and it will do a lot in helping the
channel grow oh and you can like and
share this video
we've seen all shades of sports anime
from the dramatic to the high tension
action-packed blockbusters that have
come to define the genre in the modern
era but i don't think we've seen
anything as high-stakes as this frankly
i don't think the characters in universe
have either here the most promising
strikers in japan get sent into blue
lock a prison-like facility where they
do battle the survivor earns a slot to
be the national team striker and as for
the losers they get banned from joining
the team forever however such a
high-stakes environment only brings out
the best in the strongest players and
one such contender is yoichi isagi
carrying a burden with him he joins the
bluelock project staking his dreams his
desires his everything in his dream to
lead the japanese team to eternal glory
this is looking to be a dark horse title
this fall and i'm excited to see how
this one's going to turn out
up next we have to your eternity's
second season
this came as a bit of a surprise when it
was announced honestly speaking i sang a
lot of praises for to your eternity when
i was previewing and recapping it in my
seasonal list for 2021 however i do
admit that the show is quite niche in
spite of the good writing it just
doesn't have the elements for mass
appeal to the mainstream audience so i
was surprised that they decided to give
this one a second season not that i'm
complaining though because i actually
really enjoyed to your eternity you just
don't see supernatural drama like this
anymore something that's more of a slow
burn and is more introspective for lack
of a better term it's quite creative in
its approach and while the shows are
strongest at the start i still do have
high hopes for season two there are
still more people and places for fooshi
to explore and along with it more faces
of life that the creator could impart on
us after all the season 2 arc starts off
slow but ends up being some of the best
material that the manga has so far and
that alone makes me very excited for it
[Music]
as we enter our top three we get
ourselves another season of mob psycho
100.00
looking at mom's psycho gives me the
same sense of nostalgia my hero academia
does they aired alongside each other and
have quickly built a legacy for
themselves between the two i do like mob
psycho more and it's largely due to the
more focused scope and the themes that i
feel resonate with me more i'm also not
a complete sucker for sakuga but mom
psycho also boasts some of the most
eye-popping fight scenes both in terms
of animation and stakes i really don't
mind a third season of it after the
amount of immersion and entertainment
the first two seasons have given me
having to contend with a lot of other
big hits this season could do a number
on mob psycho's popularity but i'm sure
that in terms of the actual content we
fans are not going to be disappointed
studio bones has always done a great job
with the series and i'm expecting an
even better adaptation in this climactic
season
second spot belongs to a new face in
town chainsaw man
[Music]
for months people have raved about
chainsaw man non-stop the moment the
anime got announced it was all people
could talk about that makes it an
automatic shoe-in for the second spot on
this list now doesn't it after reading
the manga though it's easy to understand
what the hype was all about despite
being a jump series chainsaw man pushes
the boundary in terms of violence and
themes it's a very intense story that's
earned its way to the hearts of many
readers through its edginess and how
unexpected everything is from the
subversion to the sheer magnitude of
tragedy chainsaw man is not your usual
jump offering the anime version
reportedly will have no censoring so
that should be fun to watch how will the
whole of chainsaw man translate in anime
format there's only one way to find out
[Music]
at number one is an old face making a
long awaited and triumphant return it's
bleach
second
much can be said about bleach and it's a
series that's been as polarizing as it's
shown in contemporaries in the 2000s but
what can't be denied is this legacy and
how it opened the gates to a lot of
people to enjoy anime in the modern era
after the anime ended a decade ago
people have been clamoring for its
return half a decade after its ending
the bleach anime is coming back with a
vengeance giving us the final arc
thousand-year blood war finally longtime
fans will get to experience in anime
form a lot of the key revelations in the
series such as ichigo's origins the
backstory of the quincy and the highest
stakes war the shinigami must face so
far the excitement is off the roof of
bleach's grand finale and we only have
to wait a couple of months before the
beginning of the end
and that's it for this video i'd love to
know what your most anticipated title is
i'd love to hear from you so head down
to the comments section to make your
voice heard as always like subscribe and
share our social media is also open with
links in the description box thank you
for watching and i hope you all had a
great time i hope to see you again but
for now i'll be taking my leave so long
till the next video